uh we've also
uh started putting our fifth generation
of our driver our hardware uh
that is on the new vehicle but it's also
a qualitatively different
set of self-driving hardware uh that's
all
that is now on the jlr pace so that was
a very
important step for us the hardware specs
fifth generation
i think would be fun to maybe apologize
if i'm interrupting but
uh maybe talk about maybe the
generations
with a focus on what we're talking about
in the fifth generation in terms of
hardware specs
like what's on this car sure so
we separated out you know the actual car
that we are driving from the
self-driving hardware we put on it
um right now we have so this is as i
mentioned the fifth generation and we've
gone
through we started you know building our
own
hardware you know many many years ago
and
uh that your firefly vehicle uh also had
the hardware suite that was mostly
designed engineered and built in house
lidars are of one of the more important
uh components that we design and build
from the ground up
uh so on the fifth generation uh of
our drivers uh of our uh subdrawing
hardware that we're
switching to right now we have
uh as with previous generations in terms
of sensing we have
lighters cameras and radars and when you
have
a pretty beefy computer that processes
all that information and makes you know
decisions
in real time on onboard the car so
in all of the and it's really uh
qualitative uh jump forward in terms of
the capabilities and
you know the various parameters and the
specs of the hardware compared to what
we had before and you know compared to
what you can kind of get off the
off the shelf in the market today
meaning from fifth to fourth or from
fifth to
first definitely him from uh first to
fifth but also from the other
world's dumbest question definitely
definitely from fourth to fifth
okay as well as uh
this that last step is a big step
forward yeah so everything's in-house
so like lidar's built-in house and
and cameras are built in-house uh you
know
different you know we work with partners
there's some components uh
that you know we you know get from our
manufacturing and you know supply chain
partners
uh what exactly is in-house is
a bit different if you we we do a lot of
you know custom
uh design on all of our session models
sliders radars cameras you know exactly
there's lighters are almost
exclusively in-house and some of the
technologies that we have some of the
fundamental technologies there
are completely unique to weymouth
that is also largely true about radars
and cameras it's a little bit more of a
a mix in terms of what we do ourselves
versus what we get from
partners is there something uh super
sexy about the computer that you can
mention that's not top secret
like uh for people who enjoy computers
for i mean uh so there's there's a lot
of
machine learning involved but there's a
lot of just basic compute there's
you have to uh probably do a lot of
signal processing on all the different
sensors you have to integrate everything
has to be in real time there's probably
some
kind of redundancy type of situation is
there something
interesting you can say about the
computer for the people who love
hardware it does have all of the
characteristics all the properties that
you just mentioned
uh redundancy uh very beefy compute
uh for general processing as well as you
know inference
and ml models it is some of the more
sensitive stuff that
i don't want to get into for ip reasons
but yeah it can
be shared a little bit uh in terms of
the specs
of the sensors that we have on the car
you know we actually shared
some videos of what our lighter seas
uh lighters see in the world we have 29
cameras we have
five lighters we have six raiders on
these vehicles
and you can kind of get a feel for it
the amount of data that they're
producing that all has to be processed
in real time
uh to you know do perception to do
complex reasoning
and kind of gives you some idea of how
beefy those computers are but i want to
get into specifics of exactly how we
build them okay well let me try some
more questions that you can't get into
the specifics of like gpu wise is that
something you can get into
you know i know that google works with
tpus and so on i mean
for machine learning folks it's kind of
interesting or is there no
how do i ask it uh i've been talking to
people
in the government about ufos and they
don't answer any questions so this is
this is how i feel right now asking
about gpus
but is there something interesting that
you could reveal
or is it just you know uh yeah or would
leave it up to our imagination some of
the some of the compute is there any
i guess is there any fun trickery like i
talked to
chris lattner for a second time and he
was a key
person about tpus and there's a lot of
fun stuff going on in
google in terms of uh
hardware that optimizes for machine
learning is there something
you can reveal in terms of how much you
mentioned customization how much
customization there is for
hardware for machine learning purposes
i'm going to be like that government you
know
that guy personally audio foes but i i i
i i guess i you know will say that it
it's really
compute is really important uh we have
very data hungry and compute hungry ml
models kind of all over
uh our stack and this is where
both being part of alphabet as well as
designing our own sensors and the entire
hardware suite together
where on one hand you get access to like
really rich raw sensor data that you can
pipe from your sensors
uh uh into your compute platform
and build like build the whole pipe from
sensor raw sensor data to the big
compute as
then have the massive compute to process
all that data
and this is where we're finding that
having a lot of control of that that
hardware
part of the stack is really advantageous
one of the fascinating magical places to
me again
might not be able to speak to the
details but it is the
it is the other compute which is like
you know this we're just talking about a
single car
but the you know
the driving experience is a source of a
lot of fascinating data
and you have a huge amount of data
coming in on the car on the car
and you know the infrastructure of
storing some of that data
to then train or to analyze or so on
that's a fascinating like piece of it
that that i understand a single car i
don't understand how you pull it all
together in a nice way
is that something that you could speak
to in terms of the challenges of um
of seeing the network of cars and then
bringing the data back
and analyzing things that weren't that
like like edge cases of driving
be able to learn on them to improve the
system to to
see where things went wrong with where
things went right
and analyze all that kind of stuff is
there something interesting there
in the from an engineering perspective
oh there's an incredible
uh amount of really interesting work
that's happening there
um both in the you know the real-time
operation of the fleet of cars
and the information that they exchange
with each other in real time
to make better decisions as well uh
as on the kind of the off board
component where you have to deal with
massive amounts of data
for training your ml models evaluating
the male models
for simulating the entire system and for
you know evaluating your entire system
and this is where and being part of uh
alphabet has been once again been
tremendously
uh advantageous because we consume an
incredible amount of
you know compute for ml infrastructure
we build a lot of custom frameworks to
you know get good at you know
on data mining uh finding the
interesting edge cases for
training and for evaluation of the
system for uh
both training and evaluating some
components and you know sub
uh parts of the system and various ml
models as well as the
evaluating the entire system and
simulation
you